i figure you can never see enough
integrals it's one of those things that
it's just the more you see the more
experience you have and the more you'll
be able to solve and i got these from
ari and i uh who's one of the viewers
and uh i don't think i have covered
something like this so i decided to do
the problems he sent me so the first one
actually i'll do it in the order
different than his i'll do it in kind of
what i think as a most difficult to
least difficult or maybe that's
subjective let's see the first one
y is equal to the integral
and this is what is maybe new or
different for a lot of you the upper
bound is e to the fourth
and that might look daunting but that's
just a number right e is 2.71 whatever
whatever you take that to the fourth
power you're going to get some other
number that's you know i don't know it's
going to be well it's going to be some
large number but it's just a number and
even though it looks like e to the 4
that looks like a variable it's just a
number so it shouldn't intimidate you
and the lower bound is actually a
function of x
and once again this might be daunting
but all this does is say
you know you give me an x value i'll
take e to that power and that's going to
be the lower bound so our resulting
answer is just going to be a function of
x
so let's see what the rest of it is so
it's and then the actual problem is d x
over
x times the square root
of ln
of x
so once again this is you know might be
confusing the dx is up there it's not on
the side we have this natural log under
a square root sign this x here how do
you even approach it so the first thing
you should always think about is if you
have you know if you have a natural log
sitting here do you see its derivative
anywhere what's the derivative of the
natural log let me write it derivative
of the natural log of x
well we know that already that's 1 over
x and is that sitting here anywhere yeah
sure this is 1 over x 1 over x let me
rewrite this integral so this is equal
to
y is equal to the integral
e to the x
from e to the x to e to the 4th of one
over x
times i'm going to write this as ln
of x to the minus
one half power
dx
and there you see 1 over x so you have a
natural log of x raised to some power
but you have the 1 over x right there so
it works out so all we can do we can do
here is use substitution and you know if
you're if you get really good at this
you don't even have to do the u
substitution you say oh i have something
and i have this derivative so i could
just treat this like an x or like a u
really and take its antiderivative but
we'll do the u substitution just so
you don't get confused so you let u is
you let u equal ln of x
so if u is equal to the natural log of x
then what is
the derivative of u with respect to x
well that's equal to 1 over x we already
knew that from right there
and we could say that d
u
is equal to 1 over x dx
and there you have
you have a 1 over x dx in fact i could
rewrite that i could put this 1 over x
right here and you'd have a 1 over x dx
so let me let me do that just because
it's important not to get confused with
these problems so you get y
is equal to
and you normally wouldn't have to
rewrite it this many times if you were
doing it but i just want to make it
clear
so
this is ln of x to the minus one half
times
one over x dx i just wanted to put in
that arrangement so this right here is u
and this right here is d
u
so this integral can be rewritten
now in green
is y is equal to the integral from e to
the x
to e to the fourth
times
u
to the minus
one-half
u to the minus one-half
d u
and now this should be a pretty
straightforward integral for you you you
essentially you kind of take the inverse
of the derivative so when you take the
derivative you take your exponent
multiply it out front and reduce and
increment it down by one when you take
the antiderivative you do the opposite
you increment this up by one
so this will be equal to
u if you increment this up by one you
get u to the one half power
and then you multiply
by the inverse of this
right so you get 2
u to the one-half and just to confirm
and i like to always do a reality check
let's take the derivative of this
one-half times two is one
and then you decrement this by one and
you get minus one half so you'll get u
to the minus one half so that works so
this is the antiderivative of that but
we're taking a definite integral so we
don't have to write a plus c out there
we just have to so we say y is equal to
this expression evaluated
between
e
to the x and e to the fourth
and so this is equal to you evaluated e
to the fourth first and then subtract it
evaluated at e to the x after that
so evaluated at e to the fourth it's
equal to 2
oh sorry you know i forgot i have to i
have to remake my substitution because
this is in terms of
x well this is in terms of u so this is
equal to
this is equal to
what was u u is the natural log of x
right so this is equal to
2
times
actually well the natural log of x
to the one-half power and now we
evaluate this
from e to the x
from e to the x to e to the fourth power
and what does this become
so this is equal to
we evaluated e to the fourth first i'll
switch colors just to ease the monotony
so we get two times
the natural log of e to the fourth
e to the fourth to the one-half
minus 2 times
the natural log of e to the x
times
or to the one-half power and this
simplifies pretty well what's the
natural log of e to the fourth so you
know what number do i have to raise e
what power do i have to raise e to to
get e to the fourth well i have to raise
it to four so this is two
times
four to the one half
minus two times once again the natural
log of e to the x
well what power would i have to raise e
2 to get e to the x well i raise it to x
so this is equal to
2 times x to the one-half
and so this is equal to let's see this
is equal to
the square root of 4 4 to the 1 half is
the square root of 4. so it's 2 times 2
we're assuming positive square root so
we get 4 here right because this is 2 2
times 2 is 4.
minus
2 square roots
of x
and that's our answer that's what y is
equal to so y is still a function of x
let me do
one more
so he gives us the integral and this is
this is now an indefinite integral
e to the sine
theta times cosine of theta
d theta so once again you see oh you
know you have like wow i'm taking an
exponent to have a trigonometric
trigonometric function as exponent
that's difficult and i have all these
things here but what you see is you have
a function here and you have its
derivative right the derivative of sine
of theta is cosine of theta so i mean
one you could just like i said you could
do the shortcut where you don't even do
use substitution you say oh well then i
could just treat this like an x so the
anti-derivative of e to the x is e to
the x plus c but then it becomes e to
the sine theta plus c and you're done
but i'll do the u substitution so you
don't get confused so let's say so when
you see something you see its derivative
there you make that thing the u
so we say
u is equal to sine of theta
and then you get d u
d theta is equal to cosine of theta or d
u is equal to cosine
of theta
d
theta
d theta so this right here
is d u
this right here is u
so then this
integral simplifies to e to the u
and then cosine theta d theta is d u e u
d u
and these are the most fun integrals
because the derivative or the integral
of e to the u is just e to the u so this
is equal to
e to the u
plus c once again this is an indefinite
integral and then we just reverse the
substitution what was u u is equal to
sine of theta so this is equal to
e to the sine of theta
plus
c
there you have it and then this is the
last one and i'm not sure if i'm reading
this one
right but i think i am so i'll just so
he has y is equal to once again it has
these funny looking boundaries
e to the x
from e to the x to 0
of sine
of 3 t dt so this one isn't a u
substitution this is really you know
what what function's derivative is sine
of theta or sine of t what's cosine so
if you see a 3t here you say well what's
what's the derivative of cosine of 3t
so
d dt of cosine
of 3t you do the chain rule you take the
derivative of the inside so that's equal
to 3
times
the derivative of the whole thing the
derivative of cosine of 3t or the
derivative of cosine of t is minus sine
of t so derivative of this whole thing
would be
minus cosine
of three
t
and then you get so this is equal to
minus three
oh sorry minus sine of three t my baby's
waking up and he's making me i have a
live studio audience here maybe he'll
pick up something about integration
so i have minus 3 times sine
of 3t that's the derivative of cosine of
3t so we just have to make this look a
little bit like this and we're all set
so what we could do is we could multiply
and divide by negative 3 right so we
could rewrite this as y is equal to
the integral e to the x to zero
so let me do it so divide by minus one
third and then you multiply by minus 1 3
right this just comes out to be 1 right
minus 1 3 times minus 3 is just 1. so i
didn't change the integral times sine
of 3t
dt
this right here that's the derivative of
cosine 3t we just showed that right
there so this is and we could take this
any constant you can actually take out
of the integral
we don't have to even so this is equal
to so y is equal to but i'll take it out
minus one third
and then this is a definite integral
so the anti-derivative of this right
here we just showed is cosine
of three t
and we have to evaluate this from e to
the x
to zero so this is equal to one third
times if we evaluate this
at e to the x
or actually we want to evaluate at 0
first so cosine
of 0
so cosine of 0 we know actually that
that is equal to 1 right cosine of 3
times 0 that's just cosine of 0 that's
equal to 1
minus
cosine
this is a minus 1 3
minus cosine of 3
e
to the x
it's a little messy looking but i think
that's the answer if that if the problem
statement was correct so we get so this
is equal to if we multiply all of this
out minus one third times this is minus
one third minus one third times this is
plus
one third
cosine
three e to the x
hopefully you found that helpful and
thanks ari for for sending the problem
see you soon